allez c'est parti première question en
quelle année M Pokora a-t-il remporté
popstar 2003
2003 d'ailleurs alors tu me dis je la
mets pas moi je la mets pas il y avait
ils ont remis l'archive vous avez montré
tes fesses je la mets on est d'accord je
barre ça c'est non voilà c'est des trucs
voilà on est d'accord par contre on a la
vidéo de ton casting donc qu'est-ce que
tu peux ça c'est plus sympa ouais moi je
préfère aussi moi je suis pas là pour
voir des fesses et on voit casser tous
les weekends je devais tout rouge
bonjour bonjour
non non c'est moi en fait c'est le
métier que je rêve de faire depuis que
je suis tout gamin et j'ai dit c'est
maintenant ou jamais quoi
[Musique]
Matthieu à l'atelier
il y a un truc déjà il y a un truc et je
voudrais dire il y a un mec que je kiffe
là c'est Roberto sur Léo c'est l'ancien
patron d'énergie c'est un grand monsieur
de la musique je l'adore Roberto c'est
un pote à moi et lui j'ai passé des
moments avec lui je me rappelle il me
convoquait dans son bureau ton l'heure
la station
[Rires]
il est incroyable je l'adore voilà je
voulais dire et c'est un mec
extraordinaire je l'aime fort maintenant
pour l'instant il y a un point yes un
point pour switch
en cm
combien mesure M Pokora exactement
[Applaudissements]
j'ai voulu faire ses concerts et
compagnie mais c'était compliqué
sur le prochain
t'es fiancé tu es célibataire je suis
compliqué
[Applaudissements]
d'accord donc ouais tu sais pas tu te
cherches exactement
une fois
se positionner
[Applaudissements]
désolé
je te dirai pour l'instant il y a deux
points pour Sweety dans quelle émission
M Pokora qu'il fait toute sa toute
première apparition télé
[Applaudissements]
de Strasbourg
c'était sur France 3 Alsace exactement
le dimanche matin et il montrait ben
tous les résultats des équipes du coin
donc Racing Club de Strasbourg voler
handball mais c'est pas possible
[Applaudissements]
on a bien sûr mon équipe de foot
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le weekend sportif en Alsace il est long
cette fois-ci il a commencé vendredi
soir avec une victoire courte mais
méritée des handballeurs célestadia face
à Metz
ah franchement bravo
YouTube
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
franchement une question subsidiaire tu
sais dans quel collège il était MP3
alors je sais alors attends je sais
attends
je sais qu'il y a Émile quelque chose
moi j'ai rien dit pourquoi vous avez
rigoler
Victor c'est ça
salut Martine
c'est ça son problème c'est ça son
problème
[Musique]
c'est incroyable tu connais les tu
connais les le surnom de les parents lui
donnait un surnom quand il était petit
ses parents c'était quoi alors j'en
connais un c'est qui
Matthew un truc comme ça
[Musique]
mimi kiki
[Applaudissements]
ça signifie pokora en polonais oui c'est
quoi
pas unique mais humilité ou humilité
mais c'est vrai que c'est
[Applaudissements]
en 2019 dans quelle émission j'ai piégé
une fan de Matt Pokora avec un faux
sosie de lui fan de masse Baban Noël ou
un truc comme ça Noël
[Musique]
on est à quelques secondes de l'arrivée
de Matt Pokora
ok bougez pas c'est rien ça c'est la
technique c'est compliqué
[Musique]
bon alors je t'explique tu sais le
business c'est quelque chose très
difficile m'a trahi beaucoup tu le sais
il est bloqué je sais
il est bloqué
[Musique]
donc on a fait appel à un sosie alors tu
essayes de d'imaginer que c'est ma
rentrée
[Musique]
et c'est d'imaginer que je suis vraiment
désolé c'est quoi ta chanson c'est là
que tu préfères le plus les planètes les
planètes
[Musique]
on voit rien
c'est pas grave ça va
reprendre tranquillement les enfants
dis-moi imagine ambre ma chérie vraiment
tu as Matt Pokora à côté de toi voilà
alors
[Musique]
c'est franchement
c'était un vrai Chris
de garder un peu partout
magnifique c'est un super moment tu sais
que tu sais comment tu as remporté de
NRJ Music Awards
ouais c'est ça
le records
c'est Greg en révélation de l'année et
tes deux premiers c'était en 2006
pourraient me contrôler le meilleur
chanson et meilleur clip rappelle en
2019 mat était venu dans Touche pas à
mon poste aussi à cause de lui c'est
parti en cacahuète
c'est pourquoi ou pas parce que tu avais
un truc de chocolat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
vous avez déjà fait un truc avec des
cartes exactement qu'est-ce qu'il va
faire il doit choisir une carte
donc au cora bonjour bonjour donc je
vais vous montrer ce jeu de cartes et
c'est très sympa qui est Julie Renaud
sur cette séquence hein avec votre main
vous allez juste couper le jeu juste
avant alors est-ce que vous parce que
nous on est quelqu'un qui disait dans la
choucroute par exemple vous vous lisez
dans quoi alors écoutez j'ai d'autres
supports effectivement comme le chocolat
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
merci ma chérie
merci merci